If you’ve ever found yourself tossing and turning
on a sweltering summer night,
then you know how crucial a role temperature plays
in a good night’s sleep.
Under normal conditions, our body’s core temperature
drops from 98.9 down to 97.7 degrees
right when we're about to fall asleep.
It remains low throughout the night,
and rises again just before we awaken.
But when environmental temperature rises,
the body is prevented from shedding heat,
which results in poorer sleep.
So if environmental temperature can interrupt
the normal sleep cycle,
how might Climate Change affect our sleep?
--which will give us hotter nights and cause wide,
unexpected swings in temperature.
Researchers looked at sleep data from
Participants were asked how many nights each month
they got a poor night’s sleep.
The team combined these responses with data
from weather stations across the country.
They looked specifically for when nightly temperatures
were hotter than average from the same time period.
According to their analysis:
changes in weather and sleep are linked.
As temperatures rose so did
the number of restless nights.
Over one month, a one degree increase
in nighttime temperature produced an increase of about
three nights of insufficient sleep per 100 people.
Applying this across the current population of the US
--that’s nearly:
Filtering by seasons, the effects were
tripled in the summertime.
And the groups who were affected the most
were those least able to cope:
lower income respondents and the elderly.
Now predicting the future is tricky
changes in technology and even human behavior
are difficult to account for.
But if trends continue, researchers predict
that climate change could cause in the U.S. By 2050:
And by 2099:
These effects may seem trivial
compared to the large scale impacts of climate change,
but consider how important sleep is to our well being
and that ⅓ of us already have difficulty sleeping.
Even if we find ways to counter these impacts
with medicines or technologies,
our sleep could be very different in the future.